- À 16 ans, Sarina,
lycéenne iranienne, était
active sur les réseauxocociaux.
Son militantisme a fait d'elle
une autre victime
des manifestations.
Elle est morte, le crâne
fracassé sous les coups
de matraques de  p police.
(cris des manifestantes)
Depuis bientôt un mois,
r révolte s'intensifie
en Iran après la mort
en détention de Mahsa Amini.
(slogan)
"Femme, vie, liberté", un slogan
pour la liberté des femmes.
Cet élève ingénieur
d'une université au nord
de l'Iran dit que les lois
islamiques n'ont plus d'emprise
sur la jeune génération.
Il veut plus de droit pour
les femmes, parce qu'eeses
doivent se battre pour tout.
Ses espoirs reposent sur
la progression des mouvements
féministes au pays.
Des jeunes femmes comme Nika,
16 ans, qui brûle son foulard,
devenue elle aussi une triste
égérie de cette contestation.
(chant)
Elle a disparu pendant plusieurs
jours avant que la police
ne demande à sa famille
d'identifier son corps.
(cris de la foule)
Désormais, la contestation
s'étend à des revendications
ouvrières, comme ici dans
une raffinerie de pétrole.
NIMA MACHOUF, membre, Ass.
des femmes iraniennes de Mtl
- Pas juste les femmes,
les hommes sont dans la rue,
les professionnels sont dans
la rue, les artistes sont
dans la rue, les sportifs
sont dans la rue.
Et tout ça ensemble fait
que ce n'est plus la révolte
d'une classe, ce n'est plus
la révolte d'une partie de
la société; c'est la révolution
de toute la société.
(tumulte)
- De Téhéran à Sanandaj,
capitale du Kurdistan,
les manifestations sont
réprimées dans le sang.
THOMAS JUNEAU, prof., École sup.
d'affairesububliques, U. Ottawa
- C'est une repression qui va
en augmentant, qui est massive,
c'est-à-dire on tire dans
des foules sans discrimination,
qui est ciblée, c'est-à-dire
qu'on va identifier les leaders
émergents pour les arrêter,
et qui est aussi cyber,
c'est-à-dire que le régime
est devenu très bons au fil
des années pour utiliser
des outils virtuels pour
asseoir son pouvr,r,
en fermant l'internet.
- Cette enfant de l'Iran
a disparu, mais son visage,
à l'instar d'autres, continue
de nourrir la résistance.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et de faire tomber le voile sur
ce qui se passe dans ce pays.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.